welcome back during our last visit we
work with stackdriver to set up sli
monitoring for application latency today
we're gonna see what happens when our
application has a latency issue well
diagnose and treat the problem and
restore our service back to health this
is the stack doctor
[Music]
now you may recall that the last time
you were here we created an alerting
policy that would let us know if the
latency of our service went above our
desired threshold checking in on it it
looks like there's an incident in
progress it seems that there's an issue
that's affecting our response times it's
time to operate now before we start
cutting we should first figure out
what's going on
we'll use tres to do that let's switch
to the trace list and get right into it
there are definitely some requests that
are taking quite a long time let's pick
one of these and see what could be
causing our problem ah that explains it
we can see that when the request is slow
it's because we're making a call to the
same service repeatedly it seems like a
bug but let's compare that to what
happens when things are fast as expected
we're only calling that service once now
we have enough information to go back to
our engineering team and let them know
that they've managed to introduce an
intermittent bug in the service code
meanwhile we'll roll back the last
change and see if that restores
performance to what we expect the
incident is resolved and our application
is healthy again I'm glad we sorted that
out now you may be asking yourself
stackdriver trace sure seems great but
how can I get my service calls traced
well let's take a look no matter which
language your service is written in it's
easy to install trace and get your code
instrumented if your app is in a
language that supports the trace agent
as easy as importing the package and
starting the agent another option is to
use the open census library you may
recall that this is the same library you
were used for performance
instrumentation the last time around if
you would like a single method of
instrumentation that combines both
performance metrics and tracing this is
a great way to go
and finally lots of folks like the
Zipkin open source tracing system it's
based on the DAP a research paper that
Google published back in 2010 and Google
still uses it the dabber framework
internally no matter which
instrumentation option you choose you
can use stackdriver as the backend it's
great to have a consistent way of
analyzing tracing no matter where it
comes from now that we've covered
stackdriver trace and all the different
ways you can get it to work with your
code you'll be much better prepared to
tackle any lis
see issues that may come up in your own
service next time we'll profile the code
to figure out exactly why particular
service call could be slow that's it for
this episode this is a stack Doctor stay
healthy out there
[Music]